[Musique]
bonjour nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique sur tv 78 consacrer chaque
semaine aux campagnes départementale et
régionale et nous débutons aujourd'hui
avec un tour d'horizon des candidatures
dans les 21 cantons des yvelines
rappelons que les 20 et 27 juin nous
voterons pour des binôme paritaire une
femme un homme est qu'aujourd'hui la
totalité des postes est pourvue par la
droite le reportage de grégory canale
les forces en présence se révèle 91
binôme composé d'une femme et d'un homme
sont en lice dans les 21 cantons des
yvelines pour les élections
départementales
c'est dans celui des mureaux mais aussi
de mantes la jolie kylie a le plus de
candidats sept binômes au total le
mantois ou pire bédié est en course pour
un nouveau mandat le président sortant
du département est aux côtés de la
première adjointe de mantes la ville
ils portent ensemble pour les yvelines
la liste de droite et du centre qui
avait remporté l'intégralité des cantons
en 2015 et qui a investi de nouveaux 21
binôme pour ce scrutin
dans ce canton les principales forces
politiques sont d'ailleurs présentes la
république en marche avec khadija mounib
et alain le cam le parti présidentiel
est également en course à versailles 1
avec anne francs si mon ancienne
candidate aux municipales dans la ville
et laurent de basta ils font face à
quatre autres binômes candidats présence
de l em également à bonnières sur seine
où s'affrontent quatre candidatures tout
comme pour montigny le bretonneux avec
en lice aussi les maires de guyancourt
françois morton et de montigny lorrain
merker attrape la candidature elle
errait mai portée notamment par le maire
du mesnil saint denis christophe bureau
et fait face à cinq autres binômes est
notamment l'un composé du maire de
trappes ali rabais et un autre avec
l'édile de la verrière nicolas dainville
le rassemblement national de son côté a
investi 20 binôme et a apporté son
soutien à un autre aligné dans le canton
de saint germain en laye dans celui de
mantes la jolie le rn a choisi d'opposer
au président sortant du département un
duo composé de l'ancien numéro un du
parti dans les yvelines mathilde andrew
et et de l'ex maire de mantes la ville
cyril note élus pendant six ans dans la
commune c'est aussi dans ce canton de
mantes-la-jolie que la gauche fait quasi
front commun avec une candidature
commune de la france insoumise d'europe
écologie les verts et du parti
socialiste
portée par audrey alliés dylan guelton
et avec monique brochot et pierre
stillman en suppléant union qui n'est
pas effective sur l'ensemble des 21
cantons du département
la gauche y est certes présentes mais se
lance en ordre dispersé aligné dans de
nombreux cantons la candidature d'europe
écologie les verts par exemple est porté
notamment par le co secrétaire régional
du parti david jutier à rambouillet
contre trois autres binômes candidats
les élections départementales tout comme
les régionales sont programmées les 20
et 27 juin prochains
la liste de l'ensemble des mines sommes
candidats est consultable sur le site
internet de la préfecture des yvelines
du côté de mantes-la-jolie donc sept
binômes se présente devant les électeurs
un canton tout particulier on vient de
le voir puisque le président sortant du
conseil départemental et pierre bédier
ci représentent et la campagne s'annonce
donc difficile face au rassemblement
national revanchard après son échec aux
élections municipales à mantes la ville
et on suivra également elles les aident
débat entre les différentes tendances de
gauche qui n'ont finalement pas réussi à
faire pleinement l'union les détails
depuis 1994 le canton antoine est plus
sous le joug d'un parti de gauche pour
tenter d'y remédier le ps la france
insoumise et europe ecologie les verts
ont choisi de s'unir
elle est venue d'une nécessité de
répondre à une demande de l'électorat de
gauche
certains électeurs ont même perdu le
chemin qui les menait
vers les urnes impossible de faire un
tractage ou une intervention où une
manifestation sans qu'on nous demande
quand est-ce que vous allez vous unir
une union qui n'en est pas tout à fait
une puisqu'une liste communiste et une
divers gauche sont présentes sur le
secteur
une candidature somme toute particulière
puisque issus de trois parties ce n'est
pas un binôme est un trio qui est mise
en avant la démarche c'est d'essayer de
se trouver un accord qui serait juste
entre les trois parties
comme il ya deux candidats titulaires et
deux suppléants il y aurait forcément eu
un déséquilibre donc la corse a été de
trouver ce système qu'on appelle du
tourniquet c'est à dire qu'à mi-mandat
je m'engage si je suis élu à
démissionner pour laisser ma place à
pierre sublime anne qui est qui mon
suppléant l'alliance et entendu est
accordé sur plusieurs points en vue
d'une potentielle victoire le 20 juin
prochain entre action sociale et gestion
d'urgence se trouve également un combat
en interne
la première priorité pour moi c'est le
regard le regard sur ce qui est fait
dans ce conseil départemental
complètement opaque complètement
verrouillé nous on veut mettre en place
des systèmes d'audit des systèmes de
concertation pour témoigner au fur et à
mesure des avancements voilà de ce qui
se passe de ce qui se passe en interne
parce que jean lui c'est un constat
personne ne le sait il manoeuvre
politique qui vise la réconciliation
avec les électeurs de la gauche face aux
têtes d'affiché positionné par les
républicains et le rassemblement
national
un dénouement à suivre de près sur le
canton de montigny le bretonneux à
présent qui recoupe également la ville
de guyancourt la gauche part en revanche
pleinement unis au sein de ce binôme le
maire de guyancourt justement françois
morton et ligny monteyne claire
l'avenant
la gauche compte bien reprendre le
canton de montigny le bretonneux
remportées par la droite et le centre
lors des dernières élections
départementales en 2015 pour ce faire
une unique candidature de cette
sensibilité et en lice la gauche unie et
citoyenne pour montigny guyancourt et
les portés par le maire de guyancourt
françois morton est clair l'avenant
président dème qui compte cinq élus
d'opposition au conseil municipal de
montigny le bretonneux et des valeurs de
gauche en commun même si aucun est
affilié à un parti
claire cindy guillaume et moi même ne
nous sommes d'adhérents d'aucun parti
politique ça a pu nous arriver dans
notre parcours peut-être que ça arrivera
par la suite dans ce parcours on n'en
sait rien en tout cas pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas ça ne veut pas dire que
nous rejetons les organisations
politiques bien évidemment on est dans
une configuration assez inédite je pense
par rapport à ce qui se passe partout
ailleurs où dans notre canton c'est la
gauche qui est unie face à trois
candidatures de droite et d'extrême
droite
et ça c'est une vraie fierté et c'est
aussi si on a tant travaillé pour en
arriver là c'est aussi parce que on
pense qu'il ya une réelle opportunité de
pouvoir remporter ce canton de pourra
accéder à des postes au conseil
départemental parler des engagements des
deux candidats la santé les solidarités
avec le redéploiement des centres de
protection maternelle et infantile les
collèges en redéfinissant le
fonctionnement actuel de la restauration
scolaire et en privilégiant les circuits
courts
enfin le logement et les mobilités
favoriser la mixité sociale ou encore
améliorer le réseau cyclable et des
propositions animé par une seule
conviction l'écologie
l'écologie c'est pas juste enfin manger
bio et faire du vélo pour aller au
marché non il faut vraiment l'envisager
globalement et ça s'intègre complètement
aussi avec la solidarité avec soutenir
les familles les pluies les plus
précaires et redonner du pouvoir d'achat
aux gens par ce genre de moyens windows
nous allons faire en sorte d'être
entendu par rapport à ses priorités je
je je veux je sens que nous souhaitons
tous que le département des yvelines
ce que ressentent réellement je vais lui
martelé durant la campagne vous l'avez
vous
entendent ou un certain nombre de fois
dans nos bouches se recentre sur ses
actions de solidarité face à claire
l'avenant et françois morton trois
autres binômes celui de la majorité
sortante ensemble pour les yvelines de
la république en marché du rassemblement
national scrutin au programme les 20 et
27 juin prochains autre canton celui de
poissy qui couvre également les ville
d'achères et de carrières sous poissy en
2015 karl olive l'avait emporté au
second tour avec 78% des suffrages face
au front national il se représente cette
année écoutez le au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch notre confrère de radio
sensations à poissy il n'y a pas de
paris saint-germain 100 départements il
n'ya pas très mauvais semble paris saint
germain à carrières sous poissy ya pas
de tronc commun en site propre
s'il n'ya pas le département et à
achères ya pas de collège schiappa le
département trois exemples sur
l'investissement et je dirais le
vraiment le partenaire privilégié
département et les départementales sur
le troisième tour de l'élection
municipale
karl olive même si vous n'êtes pas
engagé politiquement dans un parti est
ce que vous êtes plutôt proche de l air
ou de la république en marche
moi je suis plutôt proche de la france
qui gagne c'est celui des obligations
non annoncés absolument pas de la
communication sinon je serais heller où
je serai en marche
moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui avec
génération son nez c'est que ben on est
au delà des des partis politiques et des
du dogmatisme
autre scrutin qui nous intéresse à
présent celui des régionales un scrutin
qui se déroulera vous le savez les mêmes
jours mais le déroulement est
sensiblement différent puisque nous
voterons pour des listes et non plus des
binômes en ile-de-france ces listes
complètes seront connus le 18 mai date
de dépôt des limites de dépôt de
candidatures le 17 à 209 sièges seront à
pourvoir actuellement 121 sont détenus
par la majorité emmenée par valérie
pécresse
avant de parler des candidates et des
candidats quelles sont les compétences
de la région de quels dossiers vont
s'occuper les futurs élus les précisions
de mélanie poquet ses compétences bien
là elle depuis le 1er janvier 2016 la
loi notre confier de nouvelles
compétences aux régions
la région à la gestion de la mobilité
urbaine sur son territoire pour les
transports en commun la gestion est à la
charge du syndicat de transport
ile-de-france mobilité présidée par le
ou la présidente de région par
convention 1500 lignes de bus 14 métro
du tramway ou encore treize lignes de
trains et de rer
la région ile de france occupe de 465
lycées publics
elle en assure la construction
l'extension les réparations l'équipement
et le fonctionnement et les régions
doivent aussi définir une stratégie
régionale pour l'enseignement supérieur
la recherche et l'innovation elle la
région est chargé de la politique
d'accès à la formation professionnelle
des jeunes et adultes une offre
territorialisée par bassin d'emploi
s'y ajoutent l'apprentissage l'insertion
des jeunes en difficulté et les
formations en alternance
l'île de france est aussi en charge de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
l'environnement gestion des déchets des
parcs naturels régionaux plan régional
pour la qualité de l'air elle suit le
sdrif schéma directeur spécifique
réévalué en 2019
la collective
et doit établir un chemin régional de
développement économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation
il est défini pour indiquer les
orientations en matière d' aides aux
entreprises à leurs innovations et les
aides à l'investissement immobilier elle
la région assure la gestion des
programmes européens comme le feder et
l'aide entreprises collectivités
associations et milieu éducatif a
sollicité des financements européens
pour leur projet la région partagent
aussi des compétences avec le
département elles sont au nombre de 6 le
tourisme la culture le sport la
promotion des langues régionales
l'éducation populaire ou encore la lutte
contre la fracture numérique et mercredi
prochain nous reviendrons notamment sur
les compétences spécifiques du conseil
départemental cette fois ci c'est la fin
du set 8 politique pour cette semaine
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tous les reportages et émissions
consacrées à ces élections
à très bientôt
[Musique]